- The two lawyers who fire
bombed an NYP police car
in the BLM protests last year
have reached a deal with prosecutors.
The two attorneys at issue,
one of whom was an associate
at a very fancy New York law firm,
have agreed to plead guilty to one count
of making or possessing
a destructive device.
That carries a maximum
term of 10 years in prison,
though they probably won't
receive anything like that.
Though it is possible that the judge
might use a terrorism enhancement
when deciding on the sentence, but still,
they're not gonna get 10 years,
they'll get less than that
and they will probably be disbarred
for being convicted of this felony crime.
So just goes to show you,
you might agree with
someone's political stance,
but that doesn't give you the right
to use a Molotov cocktail
to try and get your desired result
or we'll see you in court.